presidente de la Comisión Interamericana
de Derechos Humanos presentó el informe
de 113 páginas reunido tras audiencias
en algunas localidades del Perú donde se
ha registrado un alto número de muertos
y heridos con lesiones en la parte
superior del cuerpo producido por armas
de fuego también se ha registrado un
alto número de víctimas por parte de la
población indígena que ni siquiera se
encontraba participando en las protestas
el organismo señala que al haberse
producido muertes perpetrados por
agentes del Estado deben ser calificados
como masacre se recomienda que los casos
sean investigados juzgados y sancionados
el organismo también reporta la
estigmatización hacia la población
indígena porque han sido tratados señala
como indios cholos terrucos entre otros
términos
bueno y el gobierno de dinavoluarte
aseguró respetar pero no compartir estas
conclusiones que más reacciones ha
generado en las autoridades este reporte
justamente la presidenta Dina boluarte
ha rechazado las acusaciones de lo que
se denomina como ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y también masacre la
mandataria ha señalado que como todo
reporte cuestionado no lo comparte pero
respeta la mandataria ha dicho que su
gobierno Respeta los derechos humanos y
ha negado esta estigmatizaciones hacia
la población indígena por su parte el
Primer Ministro Alberto taruela ha sido
enfático al señalar que el reporte de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos no tiene ningún tipo de
acusación penal sin embargo ha prometido
establecer mecanismos para que el estado
peruano haga un acompañamiento al
organismo y prometió que se le dará toda
la facilidades Mientras tanto en el
congreso de este país sectores de
derecha señalan de sesgado al informe y
piden que el Perú se retire de la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos